yo um do you feel like any I mean
because because I do feel like you are
one of the few guys who like is a good
role model for kids
um do you do you feel like there was a
certain point in time or you kind of
started to feel that responsibility uh
on the energy you're putting out in the
world yeah for sure like when um when
artists were rap to me my I mean when
kids was rapping to me my songs and my
kids was wanting to like get Nerf guns
just off base like when I was first
coming out how many guns real guns I had
in my video like nail want the Nerf guns
and all that so I started to realize my
influence and you know Nerf guns
graduated to BB guns and BB guns
graduated to the real guy so
it's just trying to fix that you know so
I've always like my music probably all
the time don't reflect the most positive
for me as a person I know like okay I
can give them net you know just like you
said he he look on his iPad look at my
tick tocks like he'll probably see my
music hear my music but he'll also see
right a goofy side a personality of him
you know that everyone has I also think
too like just like the when you do
interviews when you're like when you're
like I mean music is one thing right
like you're gonna you gotta Express
Yourself artistically however you're
feeling that day but at the same time
like when you sit down or you go on live
or you talk to fans you do interviews
there's a certain energy that you put
out there that's almost positive always
did you see uh NBA young boy had an
interview recently where he was like
kind of
communicating how regret how he regrets
some of the [__] he's put it into the
air yeah yeah that's all that's all I
feel like it's it's a lot of you know I
feel like we've watched y'all kind of
grow up man so it's like dope to see
kind of
because as a as an old head as they
would say I mean some of the [__] I'd
just be like stressed out for you man
yeah I'm like man these [__]
got B for everybody yeah it'd be a lot
of [__] going on yeah man it's just
like I'm sure it's like hard to like you
got a studio session in the city maybe
you're not from like you always got to
be on your toe I mean you should always
be on your toes let's be clear you
should always make sure that you know
your guard is up but you know do you
feel like a lot more at peace now oh
yeah I always feel that peace you know
um I just know what a guy got over my
life I know the protection he has over
my life no discernment and the intuition
I have rather is going to here going to
there or staying here or staying there
so never really like not at peace with
any situation because I just know like
at the end of the day I'm guided and
protected you know beyond anything